foreign
and welcome back to another video by
simply learn in today's video on react
versus next JS we will talk about the
differences between react.js and nexjs
as many people think that react and next
JS works the same we will compare react
and next JS and how exactly they work
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and
press the Bell icon so you will get all
the updates from Simply learn before we
jump to the video do you know according
to Glassdoor the average salary of a
full stack developer in US is 70 000 US
dollar per annum and it can go up to 125
dollar per annum in fact by 2024 there
will be 27 increase in the jobs for
developers according to the US Bureau of
Labor and statistics so now is the best
time to start picking up your knowledge
needed to get started in this career
if you want to become a software
developer consider the course on full
stack developer mean stack by
simplylearn and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description box for more details so now
I would like to ask you guys one
question
so is react a framework or a library
pause this video and comment in the
comment section below with the correct
answer so first we'll start with what
react.js and nexjs is after that we'll
see the differences between react and
next.js we will cover the differences
between in terms of performance
development cost community and many more
moving ahead we'll talk about the
features of react and next.js and then
we will see where next and react.js are
used so without further Ado let's begin
so what is react.js
react is a JavaScript library that
builds fast interactive mobile and web
applications it's an open source
reusable component based front-end
library of JavaScript
react is a combination of HTML and
JavaScript it provides a reboost and
opinionated way to build modern
application interface so the component
that user View and interact with on
screen are referred to as a user
interface react is a library that offers
helpful UI building compatibilities
still it is up to the developers to use
those functions in their application on
the other hand it takes work to create a
whole react application from scratch for
typical application requirements
developers spend time to configuring
tools and developing new Solutions after
much anticipation developer created a
framework of react the next Js let's see
what next.js is
so next JS is an open source web
framework created by OSL next.js enables
react-based web applications with
server-side rendering and generating
static websites in addition next.js
offers additional structures features
and optimization for your application
next just take care of the tooling and
setting required for react.js
now let's see the differences between
react.js and nexjs
if you use nexjs and react for your
development project you will find many
perks and drawbacks of using those react
and JavaScript projects however these
critical front-end development tools
offers a seamless and engaging web
development experience however they have
different learning curves although they
both are easy to learn now let's see the
performance on react and xjs now
performance is where next.js and
react.js diverge most the server side
rendering and static generation of next
JS applications makes them incredibly
quick they work because of numerous
performance enhancing features such as
image optimization because of this using
next.js for your project will improve
the efficiency of the development by
engaging automatic server rendering and
code splitting additionally SSR is
crucial for improved app performance
however a few things rule out in this
decision of react although it allows
client-side rendering this is
insufficient for creating high
performance application now we'll see
the difference between the documentation
of react and xjs moving ahead excellent
documentation may make it simple for you
to utilize the tools for any software
project identify the best library to
employ and more both react and next days
have excellent documentation options the
learn by doing documentation in next
year is guide you through component
constructions and routing a similar
setup exists for react also with
multiple tutorials outlining the
fundamentals now let's move on to the
server-side rendering server-side
rendering SSR a unique functionality
provided by next.js it gathers data and
fulfills each request when you have to
offer a distinct presentation to various
customers server side rendering is not
supported by default in react although
it can be enabled with the server and
configuration of your choice SSR can be
integrated but it requires more effort
also it's possible that developers won't
support this in future versions now
let's move on to the developer Community
we'll talk about the community that
developer has in react and next.js so
you should be aware that any framework
or Library you choose will have a
developer community that may offer you
proper answers or of you any issues you
run into in the Cutthroat businesses
react has a fantastic developer
community that is active in Sharing
solution via blogs tutorials videos and
other platforms we too have so many
resources on react you can check out our
react full course on the simply land
page moving ahead you will find so many
react talks and live users on stack
Overflow also on the other hand next.js
has traditional exercises compared to
other options but it has more GitHub
interactions
developer in the open source Community
are accessible and engaged in next
year's Community wise I would say
excellent developer experience is
offered by both next.js and react.js now
let's move on to the configuration
another difference between react and
next.js you should consider is
configuration react could offer better
support for configuration unless you
disconnect from the standard create
react app you won't be able to change
the setups hence you will need to use
what's already set up and configured in
cras read Scripts
on the other hand everything is
configured with next.js the next JS
templates allow you to configure files
such as Bible and test dot config now
let's move on to the maintenance
both nex.js and react.js have somewhat
opinionated cras in this circumstance
they are well maintained and release
updates frequently all you have to do is
now is to keep up with the new updates
so it's an amazing features on both
react and next.js let's see the
development cost of react nxjs next JS
and react do not make into the top
paying Innovation list furthermore they
both are open source as a result
building an application based on these
technologies will be relatively
inexpensive now let's see the features
of react and nexjs
as we know nexjs uses react to develop
single page application
here are the features you can leverage
to create ready to go Application by
using next.js so some of them are server
side rendering static export
pre-rendering automatic build size
optimization
while talking about react it offers a
routing and State Management patterns
with libraries like Redux
react can be used to customize any
project
now let's see where react.js is used
react is used in social media platforms
like Facebook Instagram pin interest
Twitter and economy platforms like
Airbnb lift user
I repeat Uber
media platforms like Yahoo online video
streaming platforms like Netflix
SAS tools like send grid and zapper
Envision app now we'll see where next.js
is used
next yes is used to develop e-commerce
website marketing websites and landing
page because it's a static site
generator
in summary well react is a library for
building user interface next.js is a
framework built on top of react that
adds several features to make it easier
to build protection ready application
such as server side rendering Celtic
style generation and built-in routing
so let's wrap up this video on react
versus next.js we hope you had a lot to
learn and if you have any suggestions or
doubt please write them down in the
comment section below thank you so much
for tuning in today and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here